hello everyone we are briefly
interrupting the capablanca saga as the
Chess Club Championship of my chess club
has started and I will show a few games
that seems in seem interesting this is a
game I played against a colleague from
the club Antonio course and we're not
just colleagues from from our Chess Club
we also sometimes play leagues sometimes
we play some hearthstone and stuff
sometimes we go out for a beer and in
this game it's very interesting that I
always as I don't play all that much
over the board chess or or tournament
chess I usually play only my chess club
championship and maybe a few games here
and there but some for some reason I
always get the white pieces against him
and I think it's like the third or
fourth year in a row that I actually the
same line against him wanting to see if
he prepared something for it and but but
before I show you the game I would like
to invite everyone to check out a very
nice animation video made by John
Richardson it's there we have this is a
an image from the video it's a video of
of Anna Rudolph and myself analyzing
again between alpha 0 and stockfish it's
it's really well made and you know
spoiler alert at some moments in the
video I transform into the hoody guy so
be sure to check it out the link to the
link to it will be the first thing you
will see in the description below so
getting back to this game like I said I
have the white pieces and I opened with
e4 my opponent plays c5 and here I
played but first I would like to show
you a few moves from the game magnus
carlsen vs. ernesto in our kiev from the
2017
world blitz championship hero the moment
were : played a3 the manga any variation
as it is somewhat silly is similar to
what we played in this game knight c6
was played and then before that there's
this sacrifice of a pawn on the
queenside so you can grab more space in
the center see captures pawn captures
Knight captures and then DeForest played
so this is a the better version of what
we played in this game I continued in
the normal fashion Knight to f3 we have
Knight to c6 the Sicilian defense is on
the board and now I went b4 it's not the
greatest of moves I play it for a few
reasons I saw it
few years back on a YouTube video by
igor Smirnoff he has his own chess
academy which you are welcome to check
out but it's really nice it reminds me
of the Evans gambit and there are a lot
of possibilities possible here for
example after after your opponent
captures the pawn you can continue give
giving up more pawns as to go into a
sort of a win gambit you could
immediately see the center for example
with b4 or after before if your if your
opponent that captures the point with
the knight then you can use your
opponent's pieces similar like in the
Evans gambit to push back the knight and
create a very nice Center so a very
interesting idea but maybe you should
not use it in in like longer time
formats maybe it's just better for blitz
and bullet but like I said it's been
third or fourth year in a row that I've
played this against him and I always am
eager to see what he prepared this time
he ignored my pawn he just played east 6
and continued developing you know saying
okay if you want to capture here I'm
just gonna capture back how about that
the general idea is if your opponent the
client's this gambit you should advance
the pawn which is what I did b5 he
played Knights to d4 and now I could
double his pawns in the center but it's
then the C pawn becomes a central pawn
not really a weakness I decided to
attack the knight twice
I want to force him to capture on f3 so
he helps me develop via Queen captures
on f3 and here he found a really well a
nice idea he played a 5 he wastes
another move with the pawn so he already
played these six now he plays d5 to
further protect upon in the center and
Knight captures runs into Queen to e7
and now we just have to trade everything
and this is something not something I
want to do for example c3 Queen captures
on e5 pawn captures and now Queen
captures with Czech Queen e2 you can
capture Bishop captures and mount Knight
to f6 the game continues but not not I
don't know not something I wanted to go
for so after a 5 I go Bishop to c4 now
if the point is is captured immediately
I will have threats against the f7
points so he plays Queen to f6 and
although I played this line of the
Sicilian would be for plenty of times
I've never
see in this position so it's not I had
to you know figure out how to go about
it from here I didn't want to give up my
dark square bishop even though it's not
really doing all that much but still I
do have the bishop pair and it might be
useful in in the future on the other
hand I don't want to allow him to
capture here and I'm just gonna either
have to mess up my pawn structure which
might not be all that bad or I would
have to trade Queens which is not
something I wanted to do as I considered
I considered my position better with
Queens on the board for the time being
so I played Knight captures on d4 we
have seek after Sundy for and now I
Castle and here I really like my
position I have a really strong Bishop
here my pawn on d5 is actually very nice
I'm still pressuring the f7 point if f4
ever comes captures here then the rope
will also be pressuring my plan is to
play d3 bring this Knight over to d2
maybe even temporarily sacrifice on f4
pushy five and until my opponent starts
developing and so far I'm able to hinder
his development I'm not doing that great
and development wise and myself but like
I said I'm a few moves from achieving
optimal setup he goes Bishop to c5 a
nice diagonal for the bishop also he
wants to play 97 and castle and here
there was the option of pushing f4
immediately like we mentioned for the
temporary pawn sacrifice and going a 5
because black cannot capture due to rook
to e1 but I decided it was too early for
this I couldn't really find anything
after that he would just move and he
okay I can recapture on f4 but not I
first wanted to take care of this of
this discovery even though for the
moment it's not doing anything
but it's not it's not such a such a
problem d3 I played and the engine
doesn't mind the engine says it's an
okay move now there is no longer this
option of him doing this discovery and
he played in 97 he wants the castle here
and here I thought about how to proceed
here a lot I thought about whether I
want to trade this dark square Bishop
Bishop e3 I decided now because even
though my Bishop for the time being
isn't really do
anything I can always play Bishop c1
improve here maybe guard even f4 with
the better push f4 bust open the F file
and his dark square Bishop isn't really
doing all that much either so I don't
want to trade it also I thought if I
were to push f4 immediately now I still
didn't find anything so I thought how to
prepare this f4 move if his Knight comes
to g6 then he's he has too much control
over the f4 square I will not be able to
do it so I played Queen to h5 and here
the Queen h5 is actually a preparation
for f4 now if i push f4 he will not be
able to capture because his Bishop on c5
will be hanging and for example if he
goes Knight to g6 I just prepare the DF
4 via g3 also I take away the h4 + f4
square from his night and now f4 is a
move that I will play next what he
should have gone for here is most likely
d6 just continue developing now this
also protects the bishop this prepares
the development of his light square
bishop and here I continue Knight d2
maybe push f4 next one I have three
maybe double rocks and the F file it's a
game but after this Queen to h5 move he
played the g6 he Peter started defending
against threats that weren't there or he
he really wants to trap my queen with
nice to g8 I played Queen to h6 which
was fine with me from h6 my queen is
already guarding the f4 square so now I
can immediately push f4 without a
problem
he played b6 here prepared to develop
the light square Bishop either via b7 or
he wants to play a six and bust open at
the Queen side here and I played f4 by
playing f4 I realized I was cutting off
my Queens escape route if he ever played
Knight 2 g8 but I realized Knight 2 g8
was well I was sure nice the g8 was
winning for me here his best option is
to probably give up a pawn with the d5
and only after F captures on e5 busting
open DF file here Queen captures now e
captures on d5 I went upon here but it's
a double to deep on now and now would
Knight a5 attacking the Queen Queen f4
yeah we can trade here captures captures
and after Bishop e7 it would still be
better for me
but still it's a
it's a double 2d point the bishop on c4
isn't so isn't so amazing while this
point is on d5 it would be it would be
still playable but after f4 here he
played nice to g8 he decided to go for
this and like I said I when I when I
went for this idea I knew that Queen g5
was just excellent for me because now he
has to capture he doesn't really have
the option of trading Queens because now
the EF pawn is a goner
he cannot go Knight to h6 as my pawn is
covering the h6 Square and there aren't
really all that all that good most you
could move the Queen but still I'm just
gonna capture and bust open DF file so
here he played it captures on f4 and I
played the Queen captures on f6 knife
capture so rook captures and now his
knight is attacked he can't move the
night because the f7 pawn falls if he
defends it with the king I still play e5
or with the bishop doesn't really matter
if I was coming the knight will have to
move and I will capture here again the
best probably the best idea was d5 here
just going for a capture so my Bishop
gets gets blocked and only then Bishop
f5 blocking my rook but still after h3 I
could prepare g4 h5 he will block g4 I'm
still winning the d4 pawn now because my
rock is on f4 the ship captures capture
or you could play bishop or or g5
attacking the rook but now it seems that
I could capture here and after pawn
captures Bishop d4 attacks the night
rook age 6 defending and now just
continue developing I'm up 2 points and
have a bishop repair I'm down the
exchange but seems like seems like
White's position is much better he
played Knight to h5 and here I just
grabbed the f7 pawn straight up so rook
captures on f7 was played and now he
plays a6 this was his idea he wants to
overload my bishop on c4 he wants the
bishop to have to take care of things on
the Queen side but also the bishop has
to keep an eye on the rook here and here
I thought about captures captures Bishop
d5 then playing next attacking the rook
but I found a different plan so I feel
free to pause the video here and try to
find it the move I played it's
it's just I there are a lot of good
moves here but this one is straight out
winning as it wins a piece I'll give you
a couple of seconds as usual for those
of you who were able to do it
congratulations you are an excellent
night trapper and for those who just won
injured so here I played g4 and the
knight is trapped there's no way to
avoid this the rook is controlling all
of the squares that the knight can
retreat to the pawn is controlling g3
there's nowhere for the night to go he
played a captures on b5 what I played
but should be 5 attacked his rook and
here he just played rook to a7 there's
really not no good way to avoid this and
I captured on h5 he played G captures on
h5 now I'm up a piece and I played rook
to g7 just to be safe okay for the
moment my bishop is covering this but I
don't want to allow any checks or any
counter play he played Bishop d7 I was
happy to trade bishops captures captures
and here I play tonight to d2 now my
night is coming to it a rope is coming
to f1 this night is coming to b3 where
it will pressure the d4 pawn I will win
the d4 pawn eventually after a king f8
and I played rook to g5 I'm not
interested in the pawn I just want to
keep my rock on the G file and if he
plays like something like rook the g8
and then rook to f1 will win his rook so
even even that's not an option
he played b6 I play tonight b3 and here
he played before so as you can see not a
a formation you see every day but there
there there's no really good way for
black to play this position
I played Bishop captures on d4 I don't
want to play Knight captures even though
that's fine as well but I don't want to
allow this pin to sit state is here for
for you know any amount of time rook the
g8 was played now I played rook to f1
check ok now he can block I don't win
the rook but still a real character
scheme captures I just traded everything
and started bringing my King into the
position he played King g6 up at age 4 I
took away any squares from his King he
went King back to f7 king of three King
e6 King at four he played h6 wasting a
move and now I just captured here he
captured and now I go an ID to trying to
get my knight over to d5 and then it's
pretty much over
he played King f6
Knight c4 king goes back and now 93
preparing to go here and it was in this
position
that's my opponent Antonio so resigned
the game so it was a it was a really
interesting game he resigned obviously
because I'm a piece and he no longer has
any ways of keeping keeping the
opposition here but yeah I was a really
interesting game had a lot of different
possibilities but yeah like I said it's
not the greatest move to play this b4
idea here especially if CC c5 and 996
are played it's really it just gives us
black the advantage but if black isn't
sure how to go about this then then
white can always look for some
interesting games but yeah if you're
really not into it
don't play it in in classical time
format it's just silly I played it for
the few reasons I mentioned but yeah so
yeah like I said do check out the video
in the description below and a rule for
myself analyzing a game between alpha 0
and stockfish and also if you're
interested in haven't seen it that efore
c58 3 the main Guarini variation that
magnus carlsen played against MST north
kiev will be the second link in the
description below if you want to check
that out as well it's a very interesting
game yeah I would like to thank and
reports Lawrence good Burt
Maxine Platt Joe Moore and Gleb kochenko
for a contribution to my channel thank
you a lot I really appreciate it as
usual you can check two of my previous
videos your thing called for watching
and I will see you soon perhaps with
some of my own games from this
championship but also we are continuing
the capablanca saga the second game
between a couple on canadian is next to
see thank you and I will see you soon
have an excellent rest of your Sunday